GUEST SPEAKER 1:
So we built a game.
It's a baseball
game, so you have
control over this bat using a
potentiometer, and it swings.
Use it to hit the ball.
GUEST SPEAKER 2: So this
ball, it's really irregular
because it's just made of tape.
But Ideally, you'd
have an actual sphere.
GUEST SPEAKER 1: And--
oops-- and that's a strike.
GUEST SPEAKER 2: Strike.
And then it comes out of a
bar or two which can't see.
But both the home
run and a strike
will empty out into this chute
down here below the table.
GUEST SPEAKER 3: Oh, it
went a little too far down.
GUEST SPEAKER 2: It's all good.
GUEST SPEAKER 3:
Which spin was it?
GUEST SPEAKER 1: Oh, yeah.
OK, if you get a home run--
go ahead.
It's a very difficult game.
GUEST SPEAKER 3: Yes.
[LAUGHING]
GUEST SPEAKER 1: Woo!
We got a home run.
GUEST SPEAKER 3: And then
there's a tap sensor here.
So she scored a home
run and it displays one.
And now it's displaying
much more than that.
GUEST SPEAKER 2: So where's
it-- it's a prototype.
GUEST SPEAKER 1: Yeah.
GUEST SPEAKER 4: Activate
LEDs the first time.
But the models were
really unreliable,
because just by
moving the bread board
it would activate
and deactivate.
And by moving the buttons, it
would turn on and off the LEDs.
Or not turn the LEDs, even
if the button was pressed.
So that was really
hard, and that's
why we switched to
the [INAUDIBLE]..